the photograph uh the the the guy in the
old spice shirt who's about to get
drafted
he's hollywood brown oh got it the guy
in the left
is the speed burner of the group
fresh off fresh off of the week one win
and yet another week one performance
um an excellent performance for the
baltimore ravens
is second-year player marquis hollywood
brown how are you sir
i'm good thanks for having me it was
great having you on back in that day
if i had told you that day hey you're
going to be hooked up with lamar jackson
what have you told me
if i told you that i'd have been excited
man i would have been asking how you
knew
well i would have said i'm i'm from uh
the foot on the
ghost to football future for you um
what is it like uh being hooked up with
lamar jackson
as a professional wide receiver in the
national football league
uh it's pretty fun man just you know on
and off the field you know it's a lot of
excitement
and just to be out there and gaining
chemistry with them has been a lot of
fun
when you what do you what do you mean
about excitement walk me through that
for you uh because we're from like the
same place so
you know we always laughing it's always
fun you know
fun environment you know on and off the
field so
we want to see each other you know
succeed okay is there any sort of fun
that you could
uh you know talk about on the air what
sort of fun are you talking about
uh just on the field like like fun as in
he looking at me i know what he's
thinking he throw it up you know we
scored touchdown off the field
talking about you know our pot warning
days or talking about you know
you know how we grew up and we have
similarities and
and different things like that you know
with the the bring out you know left
so um what similarities are do you have
from those days uh we talk about
from you know like pop runner football
to food we used to eat to
how our parents used to act to you know
different things it's just it's just
pretty funny how you know
same things guys go through you know at
a younger age you know other guys are
going through as well
what how did your parents act that were
similar then i wanna i'm trying to i'm
trying to dive into it
about your similarities all right well
we were talking about the other day was
about
uh food and you know parents always like
you know you can't you can't drink that
until you finish your vegetables but
you know they they make us forces to eat
these vegetables when we're real thirsty
so we'll try to like
you know scrunch everything to the side
of the plate and make it look like we
ate most of it
and that was pretty fun well you know
you know what i used to do as a kid
what i used to do is i used to take the
food i didn't want to eat
and i'd put it under the plate the edge
of the plate
thinking uh that it would not be seen
not really walking through how this
might work when
my parents lifted the plate and saw a
ring of all the food that i said i had
eaten
i didn't really think it through didn't
really work out for me
how did it work out for you pushing it
to the side though uh
sometimes it works sometimes they like
you ain't even touch it but
sometimes you know if you if you eat a
lot of something else and you just
divide the vegetables
make it look like you pretty pretty
added pretty good bit yeah i feel the
need now though
uh marquis to to to do the right thing
for all the youngsters who are out there
listening
[Laughter]
to say if you eat your vegetables you
can grow in a grown-ass men like marquis
brown and lamar j oh pardon me if there
are kids out there
you can grown into grown men like
marquis brown and lamar jackson
oh yeah for the baltimore ravens see
eating the vegetables definitely would
help me
uh going into you know high school but
you know i'm on the right track now
eating my vegetables so a lot of kids
out there you got to eat the vegetables
okay very good very good that's marquis
brown here
on the rich eisen show um before we get
to your
team and you specifically tonight um
thursday night football the browns are
out there
how did you um encounter the browns
defense and what do you think um
you know could happen this evening based
on what you saw
how were you able to exploit the browns
defense as well as you did
in week one uh for us you know we always
go in and we're
you know it's not about the team we're
going against but it's about us so if we
go out there and execute what we need to
do it don't matter you know the jerseys
that's in front of us
you know we have to respect them but at
the same time we have to run our game
plan
and that's pretty much was our mindset
was to run our game plan execute our
game plan
and you know whatever happens happens so
coach did a great job of
putting us in the right place and you
know we ran our routes good you know
quarterback
threw great passes and we were able to
win come on now you didn't circle
anybody there was nobody circled
in your offensive meetings leading up to
the week there was
there were no browns that got circled uh
miles garrett
you know we knew we had to do a good job
of containing him right
and you know they have good uh cover
corners denzel ward
greedy williams didn't play so you know
uh those two guys we knew
we had to know where they were on the
field and
other than that you know we just had to
execute our our our game plan
okay and so um in terms of
keeping miles garrett um bottled up i
mean is that
is that kind of lamar's job too is to
make sure he knows where he is and
yeah and and use use his entire
athletic savvy to stay away from him
yeah definitely you know
offensive line they take pride in you
know when they have a guy
of that caliber to go out there and try
to protect lamar as best as he can
but they also know you know if he you
know if he gets beat
you know lamar can make a play for
himself so
it's pretty good to have a quarterback
like that well next up for you is
houston marquis um you're visiting the
texans who are still licking their
wounds after
the thursday night opener against the
kansas city chiefs you know
that they're not going to want to fall
to oh and two and you also know
what they bring to the table what
what do you see on film right now that
poses a challenge as we're
heading towards you having to get on a
plane uh
there's those guys play harder over
there you know on defense on the
defensive side of the ball
they fly around you know they got a lot
of guys that uh they play a lot of men
so they feel confident you know and
they're their group of guys so
it's gonna be our job to go out there
and like like last week we don't want to
be one and one so
we want to be 2-0 who nicknamed you
hollywood
who did that because johnson gust the
announcer
gus johnson nicknamed you hollywood yeah
do you remember what play what how how
that uh he first said it um
on 2017 versus kansas state we were down
like
21 and i got in the game and you know i
had a pretty good game but we played
oklahoma state
a prime game and i broke the school
record and
you know everyone just started calling
me hollywood after that because they
heard
gus in hollywood um when somebody told
you
hey gus called you hollywood and people
started calling you hollywood uh
were you you were fine with that huh
you're like yeah okay i'll take it
yeah i was following it okay does anyone
else call you hollywood now
or just ever mostly everybody mostly
everybody
who call who calls you by your first
name then my family
that's it yeah so your family does not
refer to you as hollywood
nah they either call me jet or they call
me murkys okay
let's turn you into actual hollywood um
hollywood
if you could be on a movie or a
television show of your choice
you get to be on it you get to be the
star you get to either guest starring or
whatever which one would that be
um
i think i like to be on like the walking
dead or something
okay now um are you a zombie
no no i'm definitely not the guy that
survives okay
yeah okay now so you want to take people
out you want to take zombies out so
yeah i want gonna take them out okay the
walking dead we're gonna make this
happen
how does that sound we're gonna make
this happen we know people
okay okay okay uh and so you take people
out and you're hollywood brown you're
gonna do that sort of thing
yeah all right very good um so
i guess deep down can you play for
somebody who's not a heisman trophy
winner can you hook up with somebody
who's not a heisman trophy winner
hollywood that's true that's part of the
hollywood is that you is it
those are guys uh i mean there was a
heisman trophy winners when i played
with him at first to sell lamar
okay okay so you helped make kyler a
heisman trophy winner is what you're
saying
we all did what is that what's that in
the background right there
that is anthony levine yelling at me
every time the door
opens what is what is he doing he's just
trying to mess with me
who's trying to mess with you anthony
levine why
i don't know he uh he's trying to start
constantly okay
uh do you want me to talk to him
you know i could try and put a stop to
this thing
okay he did all right look enjoy
yourself you take care of yourself
hollywood i always enjoy catching up
with you here um
and um let's let's connect uh down the
road
yes sir i appreciate it you got it you
take care of yourself thank you that's
uh marquis hollywood brown
good kid doing good things